welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this prosecutors are urging more
women to come forward in the sexual
abuse case against Jeffrey Epstein
he's a well-connected billionaire
financier the 66 year old is charged
with sex trafficking and conspiracy now
prosecutors say the alleged sex ring may
have involved dozens of underage teenage
girls
Epstein pleaded not guilty yesterday in
New York City eleven years after
accepting a secret plea bargain for
similar charges in Florida his lawyer
says the case was settled then and
Newark prosecutors want essentially a
do-over Molla legi is outside Epstein's
home in manhattan molla people were
wanting to read this indictment all
weekend what did we learn from it oh
good morning Tony the indictment claims
that Jeffrey Epstein knew that some of
the young girls he preyed on were just
14 years old and that in some cases he
used the victims to recruit even more
young women and grow his network of
sexual abuse the alleged behavior shocks
the conscience the newly unsealed
indictment alleges Jeffrey Epstein
started abusing underage girls in 2002
with alleged encounters at his New York
City mansion and Palm Beach estate
according to prosecutors victims were
initially recruited to provide massages
to Epstein which would be performed nude
or partially nude and typically include
one or more sex acts
the girls were recruited in a variety of
ways usually by employees of Epstein and
sometimes by fellow victims the victims
typically received hundreds of dollars
in cash over the weekend federal agents
forced their way into Epstein 77 million
dollar new york city townhouse you could
see the damage to the door during their
search investigators say they discovered
at least hundreds and perhaps thousands
of sexually suggestive photographs some
were allegedly in a locked safe
containing compact discs with
handwritten labels such as girl pics
nude Epstein pleaded guilty to sex abuse
in 2008 then US attorney Alex Acosta
negotiated a secret plea deal with
Epstein's attorneys that required the
former investment banker to register as
a sex offender and serve 13 months in a
florida county jail today Acosta works
as president Trump's Secretary of Labor
Mecosta defended
plea deal during an April budget hearing
the facts in this case were presented to
a grand jury that initially recommended
not initially that actually recommended
a charge that would have carried no jail
time at all and at the end of and at the
end of the day if at the end of the day
mr. Epstein went to jail over the years
Epstein's established relationships
included president Trump and former
President Bill Clinton who rode
Epstein's private jet in the early 2000s
his spokesman said the trips were
related to work with the Clinton
Foundation adding President Clinton
knows nothing about the terrible crimes
Jeffrey Epstein pleaded guilty to in
Florida some years ago or those with
which he has been recently charged in
New York he's not spoken to Epstein in
well over a decade
attorney David Boies represents three of
Epstein's alleged victims they hope that
mr. Epstein and the people who worked
with him and enabled him are finally
brought to justice
this looks like important first step the
White House has not responded to
requests for comment and the Department
of Labor has yet to respond to CBS News
as requests for comment about secretary
Acosta's involvement in the case Epstein
is expected to make his next court
appearance on Thursday for a bail
hearing and prosecutors are requesting
that he remain in custody until his
trial they say his extraordinary wealth
that his access to private jets his
homes abroad and his lack of family ties
in the u.s. here galle make him an
extreme flight risk
alright mullah thank you very much